[Music]
big big day for President Obama
yesterday this is exciting yesterday the
prime minister of Ireland did you hear
this made President Obama an honorary
Irishman yeah
as a result President Obama awoke this
morning with a hangover and a job at the
fire department
it's what my people do you're welcome
Mitt Romney had a having a good time
last night yeah won the Illinois primary
and also other good news from Mitt
Romney today is an and Mitt Romney's
43rd wedding anniversary
Wow this means this means 43 years ago
mitt proposed to his wife and due to a
weak field of candidates she said yes
[Applause]
[Music]
all right yes that's right this is
interesting MIT ihnen around me have
been married for 43 years
as I said when asked what keeps their
marriage fresh and said
lucky for me admits always changing
positions and that's my favorite
audience reaction ever horror blending
into distaste turning into applause
[Applause]
you're about to stand up again aren't
you sir yeah not that one Rick Santorum
is still hanging in there this is
interesting it's been reported that the
Santorum campaign has raised at least
$300,000 by selling sweater vests now
meanwhile the Newt Gingrich campaign has
made twice that by selling Spanx for men
now of course after yesterday Rick
Santorum is rejecting some calls from
within his party for him to pull out of
the race which is funny because I
thought pulling out was the one thing he
did believe in
hey we're all friends again
yeah that's what I love about this Drive
oh yeah that one we're okay with me we
got any football fans here what guy
doesn't applaud right violent what looks
like Broncos quarterback Tim Tebow has
been traded to the Jets Tim Tebow is
going to the Jets yeah when told he was
gonna be spending the rest of his career
in New Jersey Tebow said there is no God
everything else I said forget it you
guys excited about that new iPad huh and
you like football huh you like to watch
football on your iPad
[Applause]
Apple customers are complaining that the
new iPad produces an uncomfortably high
level of heat yeah as a result apples
now putting two in a box and calling it
the Apple panini maker this is
interesting I don't have any Star Wars
fans here but a popular over here
there's a bunch of people pointing at a
guy like your outing him you know a
[Applause]
popular Star Wars video game has been
accused of having a homosexual agenda
yeah this is due to the part where
dearth Vader tells Luke I am your father
and this is your other father Brad
[Music]
[Music]
Darth Brad
Oh or is it Brad Bader Oh Brad Baker